I want to pull back the curtain
on some of your most iconic roles
in something we like to call behind the scenes.
(regal music playing)
Okay, I want juice, dirt, fly on the wall.
Anything that comes to mind when I mention these movies.
If you will, please, and thank you.
Let's start with Notting Hill.
There's so much.
Oh, give it to me Hubert.
Remember the scene with the Brownies?
We were all sitting around having dinner,
and it's about who's going to eat the last brownie.
Yes.
When I remember Hugh Bonneville
who Americans think is a classy actor, what he got up to
during that scene, deliberately putting brownies on my chair
so that I would sit on them and my white trousers.
(laughing)
They could all laugh at my bum between takes.
Oh My God.
I remember that.
Okay. Four weddings and a funeral.
Well, I, yeah, panic.
I remember the director.
He really cause we had no money.
We made that film for a minuscule amount of money
and in 36 days and he just lost it all the time.
He would throw his cup of tea against the walls and say,
God (beeping) it, (beeping)Hell,
I can't make this film.
(laughing)
And we tell it, you have to,
you've got to shoot another whole scene here.
It's two pages.
And, he'd say but there's five minutes left in the day.
And so he say stand against that wall.
It was like, we just stand there in a line
and we just pay the line with one camera on us.
And that is, there is a scene in the film
like that. It took seven minutes to shoot.
(laughing)
Okay. I'm so glad I asked.
Okay. About a boy.
Oh the boy.
He's a big star now.
Not that baby, but the boy
(laughing)
Nicholas Hoult, by the way.
And he's hot.
Yes, yes. And we chose him because
he was such a sort of nerd and a geek.
I know. He,
I mean with all due respect,
He
He's posed as a real outsider boy.
And he grew up to be really hot.
Yes, yes he did.
Okay. Um,
Bridget Jones diary.
Well, there you have Renee who was a genius
at being British Bridget, but I do remember that she went
through some interesting phases on the way to getting that
that British accent during rehearsals.
She came in for the first read-through
and she sounded like princess Margaret.
Very, Very posh and
grand. And then the next time she came into
someone had told her, obviously, maybe bring it down a bit
but then she sounded like she'd had a stroke.
(laughing)
And then she absolutely nailed it.
I mean, it's one of the it's, it's absolute triumph.
And, and of course she did that accent
not just in the performance, but between takes
and she never reverted to American until the wrap party
when that was the first time I'd ever heard her speak
with her Texan accent.
And I quite honestly found it unconvincing.
(laughing)
I love that detail.
And I love hearing that Intel of her process.
Great. Thank you so much.
Okay. Mickey blue eyes
(laughing)
Well , well. As Jimmy Caan? And what can I tell you about?
Well, I can tell you that my then girlfriend
Elizabeth early produced a film and we had a lot of
let's call them specialists or advisors on the set
who knew all about the New York mold. Let's just say that.
(laughing)
And she was brilliant with them.
If we needed anything done, she would flirt
with one of these guys and she'd say, she'd go sit
on one of their knees and compare their manicures.
And say, Oh look you've got such lovely jewelry and such
lovely nails and they'd do anything for us. You know?
if we had a problem with planes going overhead,
ruining the soundtrack , and one of them would get on the
phone and suddenly JFK had redirected all the planes from
that particular borough, Manhattan.
Oh my God, I love that story.
I'll never forget you and her stepping out.
And she was in that Versace safety pin dress.
You know, there are like iconic moments in fashion
and that will always be one that evening U2 stepped out.
Well, yeah, it ended up that way, but I,
it was pure fluke.
We were, you know, unsuccessful actors or not that.
We weren't that unsuccessful, but we were not well known
in any way. And suddenly this big premiere comes along
for this film and she has nothing to wear.
And I think I, I said, I think you can borrow stuff.
I think that's what people do they, They you know
the big designers will lend you something.
And so we ran around
we didn't have an assistant
or a publicist or anything like that.
We plucked up our courage, ran around and they all said,
No. Who are you?
And then Versace said, Yes, we got something.
But only one thing. And they sent it round and it was
this was the one dress that arrived and she put it
on and I remember being slightly startled by it.
Oh, I bet you were.
It was hot.
Uh-huh?
Anyway, and then the rest is history. It became a thing.
It really did.
(bright upbeat music)